>> Craig: YEAH,
LOOKING FOR A 25th WIN AGAINST
HIS OLD TEAM.S DRAW AGAINST VIN
TROCHECK WHO PREVAILS FOR
CAROLINA.E LINE-UP ON THE FOURTH
LINE FOR CAROLINA TONIGHT. BRAD.
HE A BEHIND THE NET.
NECAS TRIES THE JAM PLAY AND
SANDIN THERE TO KNOCK IT OUT OF
IN.
YOU THE CAROLINA ZONE.
THAT PASS INTERCEPTED.
AND SVECHNIKOV TRIRI UP BUNTING.
RIELLY KICKS IT BACK. THEIR LAS
SEVEN GAMES.
HURRICANES HAVE KILLED NINE HE
ANDREI SVECHNIKOV.
HERE COMES CAROLINA
COUPLE OF FORMER GREYHOUNDS IN .
PASS THROUGH.
NOW MARNER.
TAVARES.
MATTHEWS.
IT IS JOHN TAVARES WHO GOT THE
TIP THAT FLIPS THIS
>> Chris: LEAFS WIN A DRAW.
MARNER GIVES IT TO
30 SECONDS TO GO.
MATTHEWS SNAPS IT
THREE.
BUT HE GETS AN ASSIST ON IT THAT
THIRD IN THE NATIONAL HOCKEY
LEKE IT BACK.
MAYBE CREATING A CHANCE.
SHOT RIGHT ON.
YEAH, YOU SEE HOLL.
AND THAT GAVE THAT LITTLE BIT OF
A DELAY.
NOW
MARTINOOK THERE FOR CAROLINA.
THAT ONE KNOCKED DOWN BY  TOP.
HE SHADOWS MATTHEWS ALL THE WAY
AROUND.
PUCK GOES OVER TO THE OTHER
SIDE.
CAROLINA G G A
AND NINO NIEDERREITER WINS A
DRAW AGAINST A TAVARES.
MARNER CIRCLING.
TAVARES IN FRONT.
MARNER GETS IT